* Musik *
(Durchs Megaphon) Achtung, Achtung!
Verbranntes Fleisch,
bitte verlassen Sie alle den Grill!
Verbranntes Fleisch.
* Musik *
Another one, und Elias wollte wissen:
Ist verbranntes Essen
wirklich krebserregend?
Eine wichtige Frage,
die wir zum Anfang
der Grillsaison klären sollten.
Gegrilltes Essen
ist eine leckere Sache.
V.a., wenn es
schön braun gegrillt ist.
Dabei wird uns ständig
von braun gebranntem Essen abgeraten.
Aber warum eigentlich?
Fangen wir mit den Vegetarierin an.
Wenn Gemüse stark erhitzt wird,
wie z.B. beim Grillen,
findet ab ca. 140 °C
die Maillard-Reaktion statt,
die ich euch in unserem Backvideo
als eine meiner Lieblingsreaktion
vorgestellt hatte.
Die Maillard-Reaktion
ist eine Reaktion
zwischen Zucker und Proteinen,
die für ganz viele
leckere Aromastoffe sorgt.
Wie z.B. beim Rösten von Kaffee,
oder beim Backen von Plätzchen
oder eben auch beim Grillen.
Bei Gemüse entsteht aber
durch die Maillard-Reaktion
mit der Aminosäure Asparagin
ein eher unerwünschtes Produkt,
und zwar Acrylamid.
Acrylamid ist giftig
und krebserregend.
(Durchs Megaphon) Ich sagte:
Verlassen Sie den Grill!
Krebsgefahr!
Allerdings sind die Mengen,
für die eine Schädlichkeit
nachgewiesen wurde,
viel höher als die Mengen,
die wir beim Grillen zu uns nehmen.
Für die Konzentration an Acrylamid,
die wir übers Essen zu uns nehmen,
konnte eine Vergleichsstudie
keine Zusammenhänge mit
den meisten Krebsarten feststellen.
(Durchs Megaphon) Tschuldigung,
doch nicht... Mein Fehler.
Mein Fehler. Einfach weitermachen.
Fleischesser
haben ein anderes Problem,
und zwar
eine andere Maillard-Reaktion:
In Fleisch und Fisch
ist Kreatin enthalten,
das sich in der Maillard-Reaktion
zu sogenannten
heterozyklischen aromatischen Aminen,
kurz HAAs, umwandeln kann.
Und bei der unvollständigen
Verbrennung von organischem Material,
z.B. von Holz oder Fleisch,
entstehen sogenannte
polyzyklische aromatische
Kohlenwasserstoffe, kurz PAKs.
Sowohl PAKs als auch HAAs sind
nachgewiesenermaßen krebserregend.
Es ist aber noch nicht geklärt,
ob bei gegrilltem Fleisch
diese Konzentrationen
bereits schädlich sind.
(Durchs Megaphon) Tschuldigung,
tschuldigung...
Sicher ist: Beim Grillen
entstehen krebserregende Stoffe.
Ob die jetzt für uns schon
schädlich sind in der Konzentration,
ist noch nicht nachgewiesen.
Man kann auch ein Gift nie
unabhängig von der Dosis betrachten.
Sonst wäre Zucker auch ein Gift.
Aber es kann
sicherlich nicht schaden,
den Mais oder das Steak nicht
unbedingt schön schwarz zu grillen.
Schönschwarz.
Nicht.
Außerdem fanden Forscher heraus,
dass wir im Gegensatz
zu den Neandertalern
eine Genmutation entwickelt haben,
die uns Feuer und Rauch
besser vertragen lässt.
Die Genmutation sorgt dafür,
dass die Giftigkeit von PAKs durch
unseren Stoffwechsel verringert wird.
Sodass der moderne Mensch
verbranntes Essen wie auch Feuerrauch
besser verträgt als seine Vorfahren.
Dann haben wir uns also doch irgend-
wie zu Grillmenschen entwickelt?
In diesem Sinne: frohes Grillen!
Schönschlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Wie habt ihr am liebsten neuer Essen?
Schonend Dampf gegart,
leicht gebräunt oder schön schwarz?
Schreibt's in die Kommentare,
zusammen mit euren Fragen
und Themenvorschlägen.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
frohes Grillen und bis dahin:
Bleibt sicher!